hot breath what is your process for
developing characters you find
common grounds like yeah what is yeah
how do you actually develop a character
that people connect with
here's the funny thing about that i
don't know
because i don't really do characters
like
bunk weekly is really my only character
that i developed from mad tv
but i never did like second city or
groundlings or whatever to
learn how to fully develop sketch
characters like i don't know how to do
that
but in my my stand up in my writing i
like to do a lot of act outs
and so within that
i start giving whatever person that i'm
talking about
um character but most of the people i'm
are real people it's my brother it's
my sister it's my grandpa it's my dad
it's my mom
so i take their real essence and talk
about them on stage but bonk weekly is
really
and and tammy is not even really a
character either the nail salon like
like she's um the person that i interact
with in the story but i don't like
develop her out and give her like
dimensions you know she's she's a
character in a story
whereas bonquinkly is the only one that
actually
like lived on as her own person with you
can tell this is how long
he thinks this is the things that she'll
say this is where she came from
this is like you'll know all of that but
like with tammy you don't know how
what her opinion is about this you can
probably guess what bunk weekly's
opinion is about donald trump
about whatever you know what i mean um
but bon kwekui yes was a mix of my
brother
and um this girl at the burger king in
memphis tennessee
but my brother before he got sober so
gone quickly is my brother before he got
sober
oh my brother was like
no filter he would say
what everyone was thinking in the back
of their mind but would never say out
loud
so like people would go when he would
say things but at the same time they're
like my god
i was totally thinking that but i would
never say it like he was that guy
he is so funny and he would make up his
own slang in his own things
and when he would say something all his
friends started saying it right after
him
and that's kind of like who bonk we is
she makes up
a slang word whatever it is she starts
doing a thing
everybody starts doing a thing and
that's my brother
my brother would start laughing a
certain way all his friends all his
co-workers now everyone laughs like him
because he started doing this
now the whole workplace everybody goes
because if there's their thing he would
just do things and
it was like sassy and it was funny
and no filter so a lot of things that
von quikly would say early on
they're from my brother's mouth my
brother would say it and i would go oh
my god i don't think he's gonna say that
done in her mouth like so that's what
where it's like
he was my biggest inspiration for it and
then her working at king burger and
being like
the rude employee was the employee that
i experienced
in memphis tennessee who i was like so i
couldn't believe i was like oh my god
this is real life you're a real person
you're really saying these things to me
okay
this is i've never experienced this and
it just stuck in my memory and that was
when i was in high school like i was
like 17
when i had experienced that in memphis
tennessee and then here i am in my 20s
writing about that experience through my
brother
whoa so that it burned in your brain i
figured this was after you're pursuing
comedy but this is
not even a comic but you're traumatized
by this person
yes yes
so you just pull like real life traits
from people and then just put them all
into one character
yeah pretty much it makes sense you know
yeah
you make it sound so easy well thank you
i mean again like i really just have
that one character
all the rest are stories that i tell you
know
they're all personal though which is
which is great and what all comics
really strive for